[Music]
hello i'm chikuri wuji and i will be
playing the role of clemson mern in the
hbo max series peacemaker i made a vow
to have peace at any cost
no matter how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it good
cause right now the world needs a son of
a [ __ ] and you're the only one i got
today i'll be preparing for the role
with dramatic readings of some of the
most iconic scenes in dc comics history
alfred hates it but i've seen him make
cappuccinos on it cranks him out
but he loves the coffee
my mama made me john stewart's square
only from now on maybe you better call
me black
lantern
it's easy to be strong when you just
happen to have come from planet krypton
this
takes hard
work
it's my first big pirate gag and hit him
with something like you're done and when
i felt the size of the explosion and the
sudden blast of searing heat
well
i had a
bladder
spasm
you're saying you wet your pants
you got a lot to learn about black
lightning
[Music]
every job i pull will involve pennies my
crime symbol will be pennies
this most fun i've ever had meanwhile
at the joker's hideout
gotham city will rule the day it
mentioned the word
this has been dramatic comic book
readings with chikuryuji
thank you for joining me for this
exercise in the art of acting and i
beseech you don't miss my turn as
clemson murder on peacemaker any
questions
only on hbo max
[Music]